PC gaming is held expensive right no
that's a load of horse
I built this gaming PC for under $550
and I'm gonna show you how to before we
show you what we did make sure you
subscribe to our channel here at
GameSpot now Jimmy tell me why you built
this cheap gaming PC so there's this
misconception that you know PC gaming
has to be really expensive but it's
actually really cheap especially when
you factor in steam sales humble bundle
deals in the fact that you have to pay
for a gaming subscription service in my
opinion it makes it the cheapest way to
game so I wanted to show you how to
build a really cheap gaming PC let's get
into it
all right let's kick off with the CPU
what did you choose for our processor
Jimmy you can get away with a CPU with
two cores but any respectable gaming PC
is gonna have at least four that's why
we're going with Amy's recently released
arisin 3 1200 at 109 dollars it has four
cores that can boost up to 3.4 gigahertz
so for the most important part of a
gaming PC the GPU
tell us what you chose man so we went
with the GTX 1050 we just arguably the
best bang for the buck Carter at $110 as
2 gigabytes of vram which makes it
pretty good for 1080p gaming it's also a
1.86 teraflop GPU which is a higher flop
count than the ps4 or Xbox 1s now that
we picked out a GPU and a CPU what did
we choose for our motherboard which
shows the BIOS tower a 320 mhm Pro it
offers a m4 socket support we need at an
affordable 53 dollars it also has two
USB 3.1 ports two USB ports and four
SATA connections since we are building a
cheap PC we can either choose between
having 4 gigabytes of RAM or a gigabytes
of RAM but what did you end up doing
dude I know this is a budget rig but any
respectable gaming pieces gonna have at
least 8 gigabytes of RAM that's why we
went with 8 gigabytes of Patriot VIPRE
elite across two sticks this parts a
little more tricky because a lot of
cheap gaming PC's tend to go with just
hard drives but we did choose to include
a solid-state drive so tell me why you
chose the muse and SSD sure so friends
don't let friends build computers
without SS
that's why I'm recommending an SSD in
this bill we went with Kingston's a four
hundred 120 gigabyte SSD that isn't a
lot of storage but it's enough for the
OS and your favorite games this will
make your PC boot faster load those
games quicker and make your PC to feel
much more responsive
I really recommend going with an SSD
like right out of the gate because if
you really wanted to upgrade to one
later it's really pain envy so we opted
to go with an SSD but we still need a
ton of storage for everything else and
what did you end up picking yeah so I
opted to go with Western Digital 1
terabyte hard drive it cost around 50
bucks and we could have shaved off
around 10 dollars by going with a 500
gigabyte solution but I think the extra
10 dollars is worth it for double the
storage it's also a 7200 rpm drive which
is faster than the 5400 rpm
you know solutions that you'd find in
the consoles alright we picked out all
of our performance components but we
still need the juice what did we pick
out for our power supply for our power
supply we will with EVGA is 430 watt w1
PSU EVGA is one of the best power supply
manufacturers out on the market and our
solution here offers enough juice for
our system at $35 we have all of our
components now but where are we housing
all of them so for our case we're
picking cooler masters masterbox leg 3.1
and just because it costs $40 doesn't
mean it has to look ugly has acrylic
front and side panels a PSU cutout at
the bottom and overall it looks pretty
sleek sweet we built up a gaming PC but
it ain't nothing without an operating
system so what did we go with so if
you're really cheap you can go with
Linux and steamos but the problem is you
know most games don't support Linux so
you really have to go with Windows you
know I was able to find a copy of
Windows 10 online for under 30 bucks now
you know all the components that we use
for our build but it doesn't mean
anything we didn't test it out in any
games Jimmy you played four different
games got some data sure yeah the first
game that we tested was GTA 5 which is a
really popular game it's actually very
graphically demanding we ran it on max
at 1080p and we got a 93 average FPS
which is really good yeah considering
that this is an open-world game where
you know we could have extensive draw
distances and a lot of different things
going
I'm actually kind of surprised that it
ran this well especially with it on max
settings the next game we tried was
blizzards you know highly popular
competitive shooter overwatch I was able
to run the game an ultra settings again
at 1080p and got an average FPS of 70
was you know really important for a
competitive game like this yeah and most
cheap monitors that you're gonna pair
with this computer are 60 Hertz is a
game you want to play at least at 60
frames per second the next game that I
tried was Richard 3 which is you know a
very graphically demanding game we're
able to run it on max but I was able to
get a playable framerate at medium we've
got a 45 average FPS there yeah there's
plenty of eye candy that you can use for
The Witcher 3 to make it look amazing
but running it at medium at 1080p still
looks pretty damn good
and 45 FPS is decent for this game
because it's not a competitive game it's
an RPG where you want to kind of soak in
the environment enjoy the eye candy that
you can use and it's go get a good
framework you know I don't find that
amusing
the last game you test it out was player
unknowns battlegrounds now this one's a
little tricky because it is still in
early access and has some problems with
optimization but with your experience
how did it perform yeah so I was a
little unsure about you know if this
rate could run this game because it is
you know very graphically demanding as
you mentioned it's not optimized very
laws it yet but we were able to run it
on a medium with an average FPS of 38 so
if you really wanted to play that game
you won't really wanted to build a cheap
PC you can actually just go with this
can you remind us of how much it's gonna
cost to build this rig sure yeah our
total came down to be 548 dollars and 15
cents before that you can get a gaming
rig that can play the latest and
greatest games at 1080p it can you know
play them at medium or in some cases max
amount so that's pretty kick-ass for the
price one thing we do have to bring up
though is the Xbox one X because it is
comparable in price and it can do games
in 4k but why would someone choose to
build this over getting an Xbox one X
sure well you know our rig here cost
about $50 more than Xbox one X Microsoft
probably isn't making a ton of money off
the actual hardware sales if at all but
you know Microsoft kind of makes it up
in the end when
sell you games and things like that when
you're going with a PC like this you
have access to the large library of PC
games in existence and access to those
steam sales and Hum opponent deals that
we mentioned and also you know you want
to like factor in like this is a this
can be a Productivity machine you can do
video editing on this you can do your
homework you can do your taxes I don't
think anyone's gonna be doing their
taxes on the Xbox one they're just
saying I don't think so maybe there's an
app for that
Microsoft get on it now if you had a
little bit more money what would you do
differently sure yeah so I'd probably go
with a beef of your motherboard maybe
something like the beat 350 or X 370
which will allow you to overclock your
cpu more USB ports you know don't hurt
you know especially help if you want to
get something like the oculus rift which
just eats up a bunch of USB ports and
since this is a gaming PC I'd probably
invested a beefier GPU as well maybe
something like the GTX 1060 but overall
I'm really happy with this build it
represents a really balanced machine
that doesn't make a lot of unnecessary
compromises if you like what we did here
give this video a thumbs up let us know
in the comments what you want to see us
do next you want to see us do a PC that
is for any PC will do now what do you
want to see us do next
do you want to see us through a PC
that's meant for streaming or no
compromises build let us know in the
comments and make sure you're subscribed
to our channel here at GameSpot thanks
for watching and I'll see you next time
see ya